This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters,
这是一个 I-Heart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，Portlandia 的粉丝们。我是 Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen。90年代的梦想正以播客的形式重现。我们正在推出我们的全新播客 Podlandia, AEO, rewatch，在这里我们将一起重温 Portlandia 的每一集，剖析搞笑短剧，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，
and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor, himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song.
并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助实现这一切的人加入我们。客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人 Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家 Amy Mann 以及许多其他人。Kyle 在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们都要写一首歌。
I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clemens. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers.
我记得你是这么想的。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch。嘿，我是 Hayes Davenport。还有 Sean Clements。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。在每一集中，我们都试图通过主要关注他们如何帮助我们改善职业生涯来帮助我们的客人改善他们的职业生涯。
The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller, Danny McBride, Riz Ahmed, and Mary Steenberg. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was?
这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，因此你可以轻松加入我们的650集中的任何一集并了解正在发生的事情。我们推荐一些我们最近与 Ben Stiller、Danny McBride、Riz Ahmed 和 Mary Steenberg 合作的剧集。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。这是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的 Chelsea Handler。每周，新闻都在变得更糟。世界变得越来越疯狂，Yamanika 在这里告诉任何负责任的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚发现 Sidney Sweeney 是谁吗？
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Tuturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins.
如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者做得少一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是 Yamanika，我走了。在 I Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Yamanika 的《你才是问题所在》。我是 Nick Tuturo。你可能从《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。在我的新播客《尼克·托托罗传递幸福》中，我给一位新嘉宾送比萨饼。我和从 Seth Rollins 到...
What are you doing, my belt? To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness, Delivering Happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutro.
你在干什么，我的腰带？Bill Burr 的每个人都分享了一片。我想我从来没见过像我这样完全失去理智的人。现在我们还将迎来更多优秀的嘉宾，包括伟大的 John Tuturo。它叫幸福，传递幸福。还有很多很多。打开你免费的 High Heart Radio 应用程序。搜索 Nick Tuturo 的《传递幸福》。
And listen now. I'm Nancy Glass, host of the Burden of Guild Season 3 podcast. This is a story about a horrendous. a situation that destroyed two families. It's a scorched earth war that shows just how far someone will go to get what they want. Cindy said, I had to choose between the truth and my family, and I had to choose the truth. Listen to season three of Burden of Guilt on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Jemis Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the
现在就听。我是 Nancy Glass，《罪恶的负担》第三季播客的主持人。这是一个关于一个可怕的故事。一个摧毁了两个家庭的情况。这是一场焦土政策的战争，显示了一个人为得到他们想要的东西可以走多远。Cindy 说，我必须在真相和我的家庭之间做出选择，我必须选择真相。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《罪恶的负担》第三季。大家好。我是 Jemis Spike，欢迎回到你的20多岁心理学，这是一个我们讨论...的播客
changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Before we get into it, two things for you today. Number one, this episode and many others are now on Netflix. So if you want a video version of this very episode, you can go and watch it over there. It really helps us out. And secondly, we have launched a really exciting new project on Substack that I don't think many of you know about. It's called the Study of the Week group. Basically, every week I send you an academic study broken down into simple English and simple findings. It goes straight
20多岁的变化、时刻和过渡，以及它们对我们心理学的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众，老听众，无论你在世界的哪个角落。在我们深入探讨之前，今天有两件事要告诉你。第一，这一集和许多其他节目现在都在 Netflix 上。所以如果你想要这一集的视频版本，你可以去那里观看。这真的对我们有很大帮助。第二，我们在 Substack 上推出了一个非常激动人心的全新项目，我想你们很多人可能还不知道。它叫做每周研究小组。基本上，每周我都会向你发送一份用简单英语和简单发现分解的学术研究。它直接发到...
to your inbox. We are doing 52 studies in 52 weeks to help make you smarter, to help give you interesting knowledge about human psychology to use at work, in your relationships with other people, it's really easy to sign up. Just go to Substack, type in your email and subscribe and you get access every single week. It is also a great way to support me and my work independently if you feel called to do so. Okay, enough self-promotion for one episode. I always hate doing that is literally my least favorite part of making the podcast, but this is my favorite part, which is talking about the psychology of common phenomena that apply to our 20s and beyond, this episode is these are just my favorite kinds it's going to be so good because we are talking about
你的收件箱。我们在52周内进行52项研究，以帮助你变得更聪明，帮助你获得关于人类心理学的有趣知识，以便在工作中、在你与其他人的人际关系中使用，注册真的很容易。只需前往 Substack，输入你的电子邮件并订阅，你就可以每周获得访问权限。如果你觉得有必要这样做，这也是支持我和我的独立工作的好方法。好了，一集的自我宣传就到此为止。我总是讨厌这样做，这简直是我制作播客最讨厌的部分，但这是我最喜欢的部分，也就是讨论适用于我们20多岁及以后常见现象的心理学，这一集这些正是我最喜欢的类型，它会非常棒，因为我们正在讨论...
the psychology of angel numbers angel numbers are these numerical symbols that guide us direct us comfort us during times of transition and sometimes pain and growth and uncertainty but also just in everyday life it is the 4-44 you see on the microwave in the morning and then the two dollars as 22 cents your soda costs you at lunch, the 11-11 on your Uber's license plate. These numbers mean something to us. And we know that because our brains can't help but notice them and feel drawn to them. Why is that? What is it about those numbers that presents us with so much psychological clarity and direction? And what does the science support about the mystical spiritual side of this? That is what we're going to discuss as well as some insane plot twists to do with spiritual gurus and the women and the woman, I should say, who popularized angel numbers.
天使数字的心理学。天使数字是这些数字符号，在过渡时期，有时在痛苦、成长和不确定性时期，以及在日常生活中，引导我们、指导我们、安慰我们。这是你在早上的微波炉上看到的4-44，然后是你的苏打水在午餐时花费的2美元22美分，你 Uber 车牌上的11-11。这些数字对我们有意义。我们知道这一点，因为我们的大脑忍不住注意到它们并被它们吸引。这是为什么呢？这些数字究竟有什么特别之处，为我们提供了如此多的心理清晰度和方向？科学对这背后的神秘精神层面有什么支持？这就是我们要讨论的内容，以及一些与精神导师以及普及天使数字的女性（我应该说女人）有关的疯狂情节转折。
This episode takes many, many strange directions, but the psychology and the science is always fascinating. So without further ado, let's get into it. So first and foremost, before the psychology of angel numbers, what is the history of angel numbers? what is the history of angel numbers? Where do they originally come from? So angel numbers in the way we talk about them now are actually a very modern spiritual concept. They are as modern as the invention and widespread use of numbers, which has actually only been quite a recent thing in human history, but they draw from to much, much older traditions, which is the belief that small things can act as messages from a higher power, and also the belief that groupings of certain
这一集有很多很多奇怪的方向，但心理学和科学总是迷人的。所以闲话少说，让我们切入正题。那么首先，在天使数字的心理学之前，天使数字的历史是什么？天使数字的历史是什么？它们最初来自哪里？所以我们现在谈论的天吉数字实际上是一个非常现代的精神概念。它们就像数字的发明和广泛使用一样现代，这在人类历史上其实只是一件相当近的事，但它们借鉴了许多更古老的传统，即小事物可以作为来自更高力量的信息的信念，以及某些特定事物的组合带有隐藏的象征意义的信念，比如看到三只乌鸦或五枚硬币或六头驴，无论是什么。这其中有趣的一部分是数字本身的历史，因为它经历了从基础计数和计数的各个阶段，人们会在墙上刻划痕或来记录事情，到算盘的发明。现在我们今天所知道的数字系统，是由印度和阿拉伯数学家创造的，这导致了，我不会说是创造，而是我们现在拥有的东西的发展，也就是命理学，更广泛的信念，即数字具有神圣的、神秘的或象征性的意义。它们塑造了我们现实的结构。现在，命理学可以追溯到几个世纪前，与这个运动相关的最早人物之一是毕达哥拉斯。他是一位非常古希腊的哲学家。你绝对以前听过他的名字。可能在高中数学课上，他也是创造毕达哥拉斯定理的人。他关于三角形的方程式，我不知道你是否还记得，比如 A 加 B 等于 C，A 平方，B 平方，C 平方，我不知道，我好久没做数学题了。但他也是一个更广泛运动的创始人，一个基本上认为宇宙受数学和谐支配的更广泛运动。显然，毕达哥拉斯当时并不是在谈论天使数字。我不会扯那么远。那不是他的理论。但他谈论的是更广泛的传统，即数字反映了事物的隐藏秩序。
things carry hidden symbolic meaning, like seeing three crows or five coins or six donkeys, whatever it is. An interesting part of this is the history of numbers themselves, because it has evolved in stages from basic counting and tallying where people would carve strikes into walls or would to keep track of things into the invention of the abacus. And now the numerical system that we know of today, which was created by Indian and Arabic mathematicians, this led to the, I wouldn't say creation, but the development of what we now have, which is numerology, the broader belief that numbers have divine, mystical, or symbolic significance. And they shape the structure of our reality. Now, numerology dates back centuries, and one of the earliest figures connected to this
它们具有这种更深层的、更相互关联的、总括性的意义，我们可以通过它们的存在来访问，它们揭示了一些东西，基本上在日常生活的表面之下。现在，除了毕达哥拉斯和他的数学，我不知道，对齐理念之外的另一条线索是天使的概念，它在带有基督教的西方文化中表现得更多，也许还有犹太教、伊斯兰教，
movement is Pythagoras. He's a very ancient Greek philosopher. You have definitely heard his name before. Probably in a high school math class, he's also the man who created Pythagorean theorem. His equation for triangles, I don't know if you remember it, like A plus B equals C, A squared, B squared, C squared, I don't know, I haven't done math in a while. But he was also the founder of a broader movement, a broader movement that basically believed that the universe is governed by mathematical harmony. Obviously, Pythagoras wasn't talking about angel numbers at the time. I'm not going to reach that far. That wasn't his theory. But he was talking about this broader tradition that numbers reflect the hidden order of things.
这种精神存在充当来自更高力量的中介或信使的概念。在基督教中，天使通常被理解为服务于上帝的生物。它们提供保护。它们出现在圣经故事的重要时刻。天使这个词本身来自希腊语 angelus，意思是信使。这再次与这种可以通过科学传达指导的信念联系在一起。这两者结合起来就创造了天使数字。所以这个关于天使保护和指导的概念，
They have this deeper, more interconnected, overarching meaning that we can access through their presence, and they reveal something like basically beneath the surface of ordinary life. Now, the other strand of this beyond Pythagoras and his idea of mathematical, I don't know, alignment, is the idea of angels, which show up a lot more in Western cultures with Christianity, maybe Judaism as well, Islam,
通过数字，通过任何事物，这是一个非常古老的概念。它借鉴了一些非常非常古老的原则和宗教。但天使数字只是，我猜甚至不是最新的，而是一种更近期的发展。重复天使数字的概念，看到天使数字是一个非常现代的现象，主要是由新时代灵性的兴起引起的，特别是美国作家多琳·维尔虎（Doreen Virtue）的工作。
this idea of spiritual beings that act as intermediaries or messengers from a higher power. In Christianity specifically, angels are often understood as these creatures that serve God. They offer protection. They appear at important moments in biblical stories. The word angel itself comes from the Greek word angelus meaning messenger. And this again ties into this belief that guidance can be communicated through science. those two things combined create angel numbers. So this concept of angelic protection and guidance,
她普及了这样一种想法，即重复的数字序列可以被解释为来自天使或精神向导的信使。她写了一整套关于这个的书。这让她成为了千万富翁。她上了奥普拉秀。它一下子火了。就像2000年代初的一件大事。不过，有一件非常有趣的事，一个有趣的转折是，多琳实际上在2017年左右经历了一次彻底的宗教皈依，大约在她，我甚至不知道哪个词是正确的，普及这个想法10年或20年左右。她完全摒弃了它。她变成了一个彻头彻尾的、
through numbers, through anything, that is a very ancient concept. It borrows from some very, very old principles and religions. But angel numbers are just, I guess, not even the newest, but a more recent kind of development. The idea of repeating angel numbers, seeing angel numbers is a very modern phenomenon primarily caused by the rise of New Age spirituality, specifically the work of an American author called Doreen Virtue.
重生的原教旨主义基督徒，并且她公开表示她不再相信天使数字。她认为它们在精神上是没有依据的。她有一个关于这个的整个 YouTube 节目。所以如果你想去看看，这非常有趣。她甚至接受了采访，我不知道你是否知道《The Cut》杂志，顺便说一句，这是我的最爱之一，但她基本上说，我后悔了。我后悔普及天使数字。为了离开这些教义，我破产了。我不想和它有任何关系。我想很多人并不知道这一点。这真是太迷人了，这些想法如何能够焕发它们自己的生命，尽管与它们联系最紧密的现代人，那个普及它们的人...
She popularized this idea that repeated number sequences could be interpreted as messengers from angels or spiritual guides. She wrote this huge series of books about it. It made her a multi-millionaire. She was on Oprah. It just blew up. It was like the big thing of the early 2000s. Something really interesting, though, an interesting twist is that Doreen actually underwent a whole religious conversion in like 2017, like 10 or maybe like 20 years after she, I don't even know what the right word is, popularized the idea. She like completely renounced it. She became a complete,
此后已经完全与这个概念拉开了距离。我不认为这意味你必须这样做。我不认为你应该不再自己相信它。我不认为我们应该抛弃它。她显然不是唯一的发明者。这是一个非常古老的传统。我只是认为这仍然是其中有趣的一部分。这或许可以作为一个教训，不要过分依赖精神导师。今天，天使数字超越了她存在，对吧？它们是它们自己的东西。它们是人们灵感、成长和安慰的自己源泉，特别是当它们在网上、在 TikTok、Instagram 以及文章中作为这些不可思议的事物出现时。围绕它们的意义在流传，无论多琳是否批准它们，而她显然...
born again, fundamentalist Christian, and she's publicly stated that she no longer believes in angel numbers. She doesn't think they're spiritually valid. She has this whole YouTube show where she talks about it. So if you want to go look that up, it's very interesting. She literally did an interview with, I don't know if you know the magazine, The Cut, where, which by the way, one of my favorites, but she basically says, I regret this. I regret popularizing angel numbers. I've gone broke, stepping away from these teachings. I don't want anything to do with it. I don't think many people know about that. It's so fascinating how these kinds of ideas can take on a whole life of their own, even though the person associated with them most in the modern day, the person who popularized them
不批准。所以如果你不想回去读她的书，某些天使数字代表什么？有那么多不同的模式。今天我只讨论其中几个主要的。最大的是 1111 或 111。这通常与显化联系在一起。与新的开始、意图和对齐。人们经常将其实质解释为一个提示去注意，你在想什么？许个愿。专注于此。把这个东西召唤到你的生活中。
has since completely distanced herself from the concept. And I don't think that means that you have to. I don't think that you should no longer believe in it yourself. I don't think that we should discard it. She obviously wasn't the sole inventor. This is a very old tradition. I just think it's an interesting part of this nonetheless. May it be a bit of a lesson about not leaning too heavily on spiritual gurus. Today, angel numbers exist beyond her, right? They are their own thing. They are their own source of inspiration, growth and comfort to people, especially as they have emerged online and on TikTok and Instagram and in articles as these incredible things. The meaning around them circulates regardless of whether Doreen approves of them or doesn't, which she obviously
1111意味着它正在向你走来，显化，引导那种能量。2-2-2，下一个通常与信任、平衡、关系、神圣时机有关。它倾向于被解释为一个抚慰的数字或一个象征性的提醒，即事情可能正在展开，即使你还不能看到结果。333，我们顺着这个列表往下看，通常与创造力、鼓励、表达、支持有关。有些人将其解释为一种提醒，即他们正在受到引导，或者他们应该表达自己，他们拥有的想法是那个，是，是，
doesn't. So what do certain angel numbers represent if you don't want to go back and read her book? There are so many different patterns. I'm just going to talk about a few of the main ones today. The biggest one being 1111 or 111. Now this is often associated with manifest. with new beginnings, with intention and alignment. People often interpret it as basically a prompt to notice, what are you thinking about? Make a wish. Focus on that. Call this thing into your life.
他们被引导去追求的。4-4-4，另一个非常常见的数字，或者我认为很多人倾向于的数字是关于保护、扎根、稳定性，在过渡时期非常安慰，在进化和个人进化时期非常安慰，因为它说，你受到保护，你会度过难关，你不是一个人。555 通常同样与变化、破坏、即将到来的转型有关。我在想一个很好的例子，但本质上，如果你一直看到它，这是一个迹象，表明你的生活即将发生转变。你即将进入一个新阶段。777 是灵性洞察、运气、直觉、更深层次的觉知。888 通常与...
1111 means like it's coming for you, manifest, channel that energy. 2-2-2, the next one is commonly linked to trust, balance, relationships, divine timing. it tends to be interpreted as a reassurance number or a symbolic reminder that things may be unfolding even if you cannot yet kind of see the outcome. 333, we're just going to go down the list here, often associated with creativity, encouragement, expression, support. Some people interpret it as a reminder that they are being guided or that they should express themselves, that the idea they have is the one that is, was, was,
丰盛、财富、金钱、繁荣、成功，甚至可能是能量回报有关。而 999 通常被解释为完成。它是结束。它是该序列中的最后一个。它是闭环，是释放，是结局。不过我最喜欢的一个，也是我个人的天使数字，如果可以这么叫的话，是 1, 2, 3, 4, 12, 34。当我说明我每天无一例外地以某种形式看到这个时，我真的一点也没有开玩笑。就像字面意义上的每天。我会在半夜醒来。时间会是 12点34分。我会点早餐，价格会是 12.34 美元。我会读剧本的字数。它会是 1,234 个字。叫一辆 Uber，车牌号里有 1234。我简直无法向你表达我有多少次看到这个。我不知道它究竟意味着什么。我认为这意味着你正在建立美好的生活。我认为这意味着你应该坚持你的目标。我认为它代表了进步和成长。这绝对是我的最所有。不过，问题在于，对于所有这些，意义可以被解释为一回事，但它们也不一定具有普遍性。了解这一点非常重要。写这本书的那个女人，显然，有这样一个想法，但这其实并不重要。重要的是它对你意味着什么。在很多方面，重要的是它在心理上代表什么以及它此刻对你意味着什么。我想这就是为什么它们如此有意义，不是因为它们具有普遍意义，而是因为它们的解释具有一定程度的灵活度。就像一首诗在人生的不同阶段可以有不同的意思，或者一首歌词感觉就像是专门为你写的一样，尽管有成千上万的人在听，尽管，你知道的，宗教段落可以安慰来自完全不同生活环境的不同人。天使数字以类似的方式运作。它们的意义不是固定不变的。
they are directed to pursue. 4-4-4, another very common one, or the one that I think a lot of people lean towards is about protection, grounding, stability, very comforting during times of transition, very comforting during times of evolution and personal evolution, because it says, you are protected, you're going to get through this, you're not alone. 555 is usually associated, again, with change, with disruption, with transformation, coming. I'm trying to think about a great example, but essentially, if you see it all the time, it's a sign that something is about to shift for you. You're about to enter a new phase. 777 is spiritual insight, luck, intuition, a deeper sense of knowing. 888 is often associated with
它们充当了一个情感容器，它们赋予形状并成形，它们是象征性的，它们通常根据我们已经感受到的东西而变得重要，它们只是成为将我们内心深处作为一个深刻真理的某种东西外化的方式。那么，为什么它们对我们感觉如此重要？为什么 111 是个好兆头？为什么 333 是个积极的事物？心理学对我们对这些数字的吸引力有什么看法？在短暂的休息后，我们将深入探讨这一点。与 Cameron Wickcombe 一起在 Ryman 直播。
abundance, wealth, money, prosperity, success, maybe even energetic return. and 999 is usually interpreted as completion. It's the end. It's the last one kind of in that sequence. It's closure, it's release, it's its endings. My favorite one though, and my personal angel number, if one can call it that, is 1, 2, 3, 4, 12, 34. I am not kidding when I say I see this in some form
纳什维尔的航班和两晚住宿。在传奇的 Ryman 礼堂观看 Cameron Wickham。外加一千美元的花销。只需在免费的 IHard 广播应用程序上每天听 Pure Country 10分钟，你就有机会赢取。Cameron Wickham。播放全新单曲《恐惧王国》。现已上线。嘿，Portlandia 的粉丝们。
every single day without fail. Like literally every single day. I will wake up in the middle of the night. it will be 12.34 a.m. I will order my breakfast, it will be $12.34. I will read the word count for a script. It will be 1,234 words. Grab an Uber, 1234 in the license plate. I literally cannot express you how many ways I have seen this. I don't know what it fully believes. I think it means that you're building a good life. I think it means that you should stick to your goal. I think it represents progress and growth. That is definitely my favorite. The thing is, though, with all those, the meanings can be interpreted as one
我是 Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen。你们认识我们，或者更确切地说，你们认识他们。Tony 和 Candice、Nina 和 Lance、Spike，还有，是的，那只鸡。这些年来我们扮演了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以我们自己的身份出现，向你们介绍我们的全新播客 Podlandia, AEO, rewatch。每周，我们都会从头开始重温一集 Portlandia，剖析短剧，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，
the same, they also aren't necessarily universal. That is so important to know. The woman who wrote this book, obviously, like, had an idea, but it doesn't really matter. It matters what it means to you. It matters in many ways what it psychologically represents and what it needs to mean to you in this moment. And I think that's why they're so meaningful, not because they have a universal meaning, but because they allow for a level of flexibility in their interpretation. Just like a poem can mean different things at different stages of your life or a song lyric feels like it was written just for you, even though thousands of people listen to it, even though, you know, like a religious passage can comfort different people from completely
重温你熟悉和喜爱的波特兰地点，并公开我们的创作过程。这一切到底是怎么制作出来的？为什么我们认为那是个好主意？我们准备好谈谈了。我们还将邀请那些帮助实现这一切的人加入我们。客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysler、
different life circumstances. Angel numbers work in a similar way. Their meaning is not fixed. they act as an emotional container and they give shape and they take shape and they are symbolic and they are important often based on things that we are already feeling and they just become a way of externalizing something that we already know as a deep truth so why do they feel so significant to us why is one one one a good sign why is three three three a positive thing what does the psychology say about our attraction to these numbers. We are going to dive into that after this short break. With Cameron Wickcombe live at the Rhyman.
市长本人 Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家 Amy Mann 以及许多其他人。Kyle 在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌，一段旋律。嗯，我以为他要写。我以为你们都要写一首歌。我记得你是这么想的。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Podlandia。
Flights and two nights in Nashville. To see Cameron Wickham at the legendary Ryman Auditorium. Plus a thousand dollar spending caps. Just listen to Pure Country for 10 minutes a day on the free IHard radio app and you're in to win. Cameron Wickham. Stream the new single, Kingdom of Fear. Available now. Hey, Portlandia fans.
Ayo rewatch。嘿，我是 Hayes Davenport。还有 Sean Clements。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。在每一集中，我们都试图通过主要关注他们如何帮助我们改善职业生涯来帮助我们的客人改善他们的职业生涯。这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，因此你可以轻松加入我们的650集中的任何一集并了解正在发生的事情。
Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather, you know them. Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, the chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters,
我们推荐一些我们最近的剧集。那些有 Ben Stiller 的。电影的定义其实也变了，对吧？你认为现在是什么？它是被某种技术捕捉到的图像和说出的文字。Danny McBride。他喜欢 Nova。哦，太棒了。
revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler,
你制作它，你制作你自己的。那太好了。我叫他 Terro Reed。这是个好名字。他们都以《美国派》的演员命名。是啊。哦，明白了。我叫，我没有，我从来没有查过她是否在这里，但我叫她 Leachy。
the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia.
Obiaski。我不认为她演过《美国派》，但我还是喜欢那样。没查过。她当时挺活跃的。然后是 Mary Steenberg。你们为什么跟我说话？我很担心。你们为什么这么居高临落地跟我说话，觉得我听不懂你们的小把戏？
Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on.
我只是真的。我明白了。我是在为你走向成功做铺垫。在 I Heart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。我是 Nick Tuturo。你可能从《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。但我也是来自皇后区，这意味着我知道披萨。
We recommend some of our recent episodes. Those with Ben Stillard. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anyway, too, right? What do you think it is now? It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. He loves Nova. Oh, that's fantastic.
在我的新播客《尼克·托托罗传递幸福》中，我把 Prince Street Pizza 的披萨送给一位新嘉宾。你现在在送披萨吗？然后我们坐下来进行真正的对话。我和从 Seth Rollins 到...
And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Terro Reed. It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie. Yeah. Oh, got you. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was in this, but I call him Leachy.
你在干什么，我的腰带？Alex Rodriguez。告诉你们各位，我们正在和这里的一位 GOAT（史上最佳）对话。
Obiaski. I don't think she was an American pie, but I still like that. Haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Then Mary Steenberg. Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me that you think I don't understand your little play game?
Bill Burr 的每个人都分享了一片。我想我从来没见过像我这样完全失去理智的人。我。现在我们还将迎来更多优秀的嘉宾，包括伟大的 John Tuturo。它叫幸福，传递幸福。Mariano Rivera。哦，天哪。
I just really. I get it. I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Tuturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza.
还有很多很多。打开你免费的 High Heart Radio 应用程序。搜索 Nick Tuturo 的《传递幸福》。现在就听。这是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的 Chelsea Handler。每周，新闻都在变得更糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。Yamanika 在这里告诉任何负责任的人，
And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Toto, I deliver pizza from Prince Street Pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here.
你才是问题所在。如果你来这里玩游戏，我会查你的。好吗？如果你在新闻里做了一些听起来不太好的事，我会曝光你的。加入 Yomeneika Saunders，在她全新的播客中剖析本周最具问题的故事。Yamanika 的《你才是问题所在》。你知道我刚发现 Sidney 是谁吗？每周三定期更新新集，作为我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”的一部分。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者做得少一点，所以我不必做那么多。
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind. I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness, delivering happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God.
所以加入 Yamanika 的每一集，因为她回答了一个问题。谁才是问题所在？我是 Yamanika，我走了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Yamanika 的《你才是问题所在》。天使数字感觉很重要。首先，因为它们经常出现，或者我们更有可能在我们生活中具有情感意义的时刻注意到它们。这不是巧合。
And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Detouro. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible,
这不是偶然。它的发生是因为心理学的一个核心原则是，我们主要通过我们的情感状态来解释世界。我们的现实塑造了我们的情绪，但反过来也是如此，这意味着我们的感受会影响我们注意到什么、什么感觉重要以及我们拥有的生活，知觉就是一切。理解这一点的一个有用方法是通过我们称之为意义维持模型的东西。因此，在2006年发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》上的一篇论文中，作者提出了这样一种建议，即人们对意义有着内在的需求。这是一个古老的想法。他们真的能够在这次研究中清楚地表达这一点。我们需要通过精神表征的框架来感知事件，以组织我们对世界的感知。我们内心深处有着将世界体验为一个连贯的、有意义的、符合逻辑的、有组织的事物的需求。这对我们人类来说很重要。当这种意义感受到威胁时，例如，当生活感到混乱时，当你经历了一次可怕的分手并且不再相信爱情时，当你不知道自己在对生活做什么时，当疾病发生时，当不公平的事情发生时，人们经常试图通过另一种方式恢复意义，例如通过天使数字的引导和存在。
you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check. you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yomeneika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less so I don't have
这有助于解释为什么天使数字在过渡时期变得引人注目，比如我们的20多岁，比如离婚后，比如你刚失业时，比如你正在经历悲伤时。这些都是生活暂时感觉非常没有条理的时刻，而你的大脑不喜欢这样。我们正在寻找任何可以为生活提供情感脚手架和情感意义的东西。这就引发了另一个问题。不过，为什么是那些数字？为什么我们的大脑从一开始就那么容易在重复的数字中看到意义，而不是其他东西？
to do so much. So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Angel numbers feel significant. Firstly, because they often appear or we are more likely to notice them at emotionally significant points in our life. And this is not a coincidence.
比如，为什么这些东西是一个迹象？这就把我们带到了模式识别的心理学。我最喜欢的之一，我喜欢这个。我可以谈论这个一整天。我们的大脑不断地在环境中扫描相同的事物、重复、连接、节奏、信号。基本上，我们的大脑想要理解周围环境以保证我们的安全。如果它们能预测接下来会发生什么，那就会给它们带来更好的机会。这是我们大脑做的最重要的事情之一。我们的大脑天生就能识别模式，这正是帮助我们做诸如学习语言、识别人脸、理解社交线索或预测我们何时可能处于危险之中等事情的原因。它是我们大脑的核心部分，如果不是最关键的部分，也是我们作为人类生活的一部分。它帮助我们学习，如果我们做某些行为，就会产生某些结果。乌云意味着下雨。如果有人这样对待你，那么它可能会以这种方式结束。而我们无法解释这些模式往往是让我们陷入麻烦的原因，不仅在生存方面，在情感模式方面也是如此。模式检测可以挽救生命，不听取它也可能会改变生活。棘手的是，一个旨在检测有意义模式的大脑有时会在模式有点随机的地方找到意义。心理学家有时称之为 apophenia，这意味着感知不相关或随机事物之间的有意义联系。简单来说，就是当心智看到一个模式，
It's not an accident. it occurs because a core principle in psychology is that we interpret the world primarily through our emotional state. Our reality shapes our emotions, but it also happens the other way around as well, meaning how we feel influences what we notice, what feels important, and the life that we have, perception is everything. A useful way of understanding this is through what we call the meaning maintenance model. So in a 2006 paper published in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, the authors kind of made this suggestion that people have an inherent need for meaning. This is an old idea. They really were able to articulate it in this study. We need to perceive events through the
并赋予其意义，即使该模式没有外部原因。现在，这违背了我们对天使数字的一些信念，但对于为什么我们的大脑喜欢天使数字，这是一个非常重要的解释。2008年，Jennifer Whitson 在《科学》杂志上发表了一项研究。她是一位心理学家，其工作探讨了控制、不确定性和模式感知。它为我们提供了一种非常有用的大量理解方式，通过一系列实验，Jennifer 发现当人们感到缺乏控制时，他们更有可能感知到...
frame of mental representations to organize our perception of the world. We have this deep need, basically to experience the world as this coherent, meaningful, logical, organized thing. That is important to us as humans. When that sense of meaning is threatened, for example, when life feels confusing, when you've gone through a terrible breakup and you don't believe in love anymore, when you have no idea what you are doing with your life, when a sickness occurs, when something unfair happens, people often try to restore meaning in another way, such as through the guidance, and presence of angel numbers.
错觉的，或者我不想说是妄想，但只是通常的模式。他们更有可能看到，例如，视觉噪点中的图像。他们更有可能识别出客观上并不存在的联系。当我们感到有控制力时，世界已经显得足够有条理了。我们真的不需要寻找额外的迹象。当我们感到失去控制时，心智变得更有动力恢复秩序。它寻找意义。现在，这是关键的事情，因为这是否意味着意义不存在？不，那些数字仍然存在。它们提供的指导仍然是真实的。只是你开始更多地寻找它们了。现在，为什么会有这些数字？那是另一个问题，对吧？当涉及到这些你无法解开且你不能完全忽视数字确实控制世界、数学是这件奇妙的事物以及命理学是解释生活的一种非常有效的方式的事实，灵性与心理学之间存在着这种深刻的交集。这就是确认偏误发挥作用的地方。确认偏误是倾向于注意到、记住并赋予更多权重给那些支持我们已经相信或怀疑的信息。确认偏误是我们所有人都受其影响的东西。同样，这是我们大脑硬编码的一部分。无可逃避。它是人类思维的一个必不可少特征，你可能会觉得看到 2-2-2 意味着你在正确的道路上。然后，每当你做出某个决定后看到数字 2-2-2，这就会为你证实这一点。
This helps explain why angel numbers become compelling during periods of transition, like our 20s, like after a divorce, like when you've just lost a job, like when you are moving through grief. These are all moments where life feels temporarily very unstructured, and your brain does not like that. We are looking for anything that can provide emotional scaffolding and emotional meaning to life. This raises another question. Why those numbers, though? Why are our mind so ready to see meaning in repeated numbers in the first place rather than just something else?
这就足以让人觉得你一定是正确的。但问题是，你可能不记得所有你做出决定却没有看到数字 2-2-2-2 的时刻。你可能没有注意到所有你看到 2-2-2 但随后什么明显的事也没有发生的时刻。现在，再次说明，这是否意味着因为科学对它们有另一种解释就应该完全不理会天使数字？我个人不这么认为。就像，我不这么认为。
Like, why are those things a sign? That brings us to the psychology of pattern recognition. One of my favorite, I love this. I can talk about this all day. Our brains are constantly scanning the environment for things that are the same, for repetition, for connection, for rhythm, them for signs. Basically, our brains want to make sense of our surroundings to keep us safe. If they can predict what's going to happen next, that gives them a better chance. It's one of the most important things that our brains do. The sheer fact that our brains are wired to recognize patterns are what helps us to do things like learn languages or recognize faces or understand social cues or predict when we might be in danger. It is a core, if not most critical part of
我仍然认为它们是有意义的。但了解这些幻觉和偏误也很重要，这些幻觉和偏误也促成了它们的维持。另一个是频率错觉。你可能会... 描述这一点的最好方式就像，你学习了一个新术语或新词，突然之间每个人都在谈论它。或者你正在考虑买某辆车，然后突然你看到的每一辆车都是那辆车。这感觉完全是偶然的，但只是你的大脑已经开始过滤重要信息。它刚刚开始过滤你已经决定的事情，这是相当...
our brains and our lives as humans. It helps us learn that if we do certain behaviors, certain outcomes are going to happen. Dark clouds mean rain. If somebody treats you like this, then it's probably going to end this way. And our inability to interpret those patterns is often what gets us into trouble, not just in terms of survival, but in terms of emotional patterns as well. Pattern detection is life-saving, not listening to it can also be life-changing. The tricky thing is that a brain that is built to detect meaningful patterns will sometimes find meaning in places where the pattern is a little bit random. Psychologists sometimes refer to this as apophenia, which means perceiving meaningful connections between unrelated
至关重要的，或者对你而言依然至关重要的。世界不一定变了，但你的注意力变了。注意力确实处于这一切的核心，而天使数字再次以相同的方式运作。一旦某个数字对你变得有意义，就像 1234 对我一样重要，你的大脑就会开始把那个数字当作重要的对待。你每天字面意义上过滤数百万条信息，但一旦某事被编码为重要的，它就会从背景中跳出来，对吧？就像在人群中认出你认识并热爱的人的脸一样。你注意到了。你注意到了。你意识到了。这是对你很重要的东西。每次你注意到它，它都与你息息相关。因为你正在注意到它，这感觉更加重要，
or random things. In simple terms, it's when the mind sees a pattern. and gives it significance, even when the pattern doesn't have an external cause. Now, that goes against some of our beliefs about angel numbers, but it is a really important explanation for why our brains like angel numbers. There was a 2008 study published in science, the journal science, by Jennifer Whitson. She's a psychologist whose work has explored control and uncertainty and pattern perception. And it gives us a really useful way to understand this across a series of several experiments, Jennifer found that when people felt a lack of control, they were more likely to perceive
那显然意味着什么。这就是天使数字如何对我们变得重要，然后继续成为我们看到的事物的循环过程。这真是太令人安心了。这就是我要说的。这太令人安慰了。这是一种好感觉。这很美。事物是相互关联的，生活有模式和意义，这种想法是生活的一种极好的方式。这就把我带到了另一个与天使数字相关的想法，也就是主观好运论（pronoia）。
illusory or, I don't want to say delusional, but just patterns in general. They were more likely to see, for example, images in visual noise. They were more likely to identify connections that were just objectively not there. When we feel in control, the world already feels organized enough. We don't really need to look for extra signs. When we feel out of control, the mind becomes more motivated to restore order. It searches for meaning. Now, this is the critical thing because does that mean the meaning isn't there? No, those numbers are still there. The guidance they provide is still real. It's just that you start looking for them more. Now, why are the numbers there? That's another question, right? There is this deep intersection between spirituality and psychology
虚幻的，或者我不想说这是妄想，但简而言之就是各种模式。例如，他们更有可能在视觉杂音中看到图像。他们更有可能找出客观上根本不存在的联系。当我们感到一切尽在掌握时，世界本身就已经显得足够有条理了。我们其实并不需要去寻找额外的迹象。而当我们感到失控时，大脑就会更有动力去恢复秩序。它会去寻找意义。现在，这是最关键的一点，因为这是否意味着意义不存在？不，那些数字依然存在。它们提供的指引依然是真实的。只是你开始更多地去寻找它们了。那么，为什么会有这些数字呢？这是一个新问题，对吧？灵性与心理学之间存在着这种深度的交集
when it comes to these things that you can't disentangle and you can't completely ignore the fact that numbers do control the world and that math is this wonderful thing and that numerology is a very valid way of interpreting life. This is where the idea of confirmation bias comes in. Confirmation bias is the tendency to notice, remember, and give more weight to information that supports what we already believe or suspect. Confirmation bias is something that we are all subject to. Again, it's part of our brains hardwiring. There's no escaping it. It is a an essential feature of human thinking, you may feel like seeing 2-2-2 means you're on the right path. Then whenever you see the number 2-2-2 after making a certain decision, that just confirms it
在面对这些无法厘清、也无法完全忽视的事实——即数字确实主宰着世界、数学是一件如此美妙的事情，以及命理学是诠释生活的一种非常有效的方式时。这就是确认偏差概念切入的地方。确认偏差是指人们倾向于注意到、记住并赋予更多权重给那些支持我们已有信念或猜想的信息。确认偏差是我们所有人都会受到的影响。同样，这是我们大脑固有连线的一部分。这是无法逃避的。它是人类思考的一个基本特征，你可能会觉得看到2-2-2意味着你正走在正确的道路上。然后，每当你做出某个决定后看到数字2-2-2，这就会进一步确认
for you. That is enough to feel like you must have been correct. But the thing is, is that you may not remember all the times you made a decision and you didn't see the number 2-2-2-2. You may not notice all the times you saw 2-2-2, and nothing obvious happened afterwards. Now, again, does this mean that angel numbers should be completely discounted just because the science has another explanation for them? I personally don't think so. Like, I don't think so.
你的想法。这就足以让你觉得自己的决定一定是对的。但问题是，你可能不会记得所有你做出决定却没有看到数字2-2-2-2的时刻。你可能也不会注意到所有你看到了2-2-2、而之后并没有发生什么明显事情的时刻。那么，再次强调，这是否意味着仅仅因为科学对天使数字有另一种解释，就应该完全否定它们呢？我个人并不这么认为。我是说，我不这样认为。
I still think they're meaningful. But it's just important to understand these illusions and these biases that also contribute to them being upheld. Another one is the frequency illusion. You may... This is the best way to describe this is like, you learn a new term or you learn a new word and suddenly like everybody is talking about it. Or you're thinking about buying a certain car and then suddenly every single car you see is that car. It can feel like it's completely by chance, but it's just that your brain has started to filter for important information. It's just starting to filter for things that you have decided, is quite,
我仍然认为它们是有意义的。但了解这些也会促使它们得以维持的幻觉和偏差，是非常重要的。另一个现象是频率错觉。你可能会……最好用这种方式来描述它，就像你学了一个新术语或新词，然后突然之间好像每个人都在谈论它。或者你正考虑买某款车，然后突然之间你看到的每一辆车都是那款车。这感觉可能完全是巧合，但实际上只是你的大脑开始过滤重要信息了。它开始过滤那些你认为相当
critical or remains critical for you. The world has not necessarily changed, but your attention has. Attention really sits at the core of this, and angel numbers again work in the same way. Once a certain number becomes meaningful to you, the way 1234 is meaningful to me, your brain starts treating that number is important. You filter literally millions of pieces of information every single day, but once something has been encoded as significant, it's just going to to pop out from the background, right? It's like recognizing the face of somebody that you know and love in a crowd. You notice it. You notice it. You clock it. It's something that's important to you. It's relevant to you each time you notice it. It feels even more significant because the fact that you're noticing it,
重要或对你而言依然重要的事情。世界未必发生了改变，但你的注意力变了。注意力确实是这一切的核心，而天使数字也是以同样的方式发挥作用的。一旦某个数字对你有了意义，就像1234对我有意义一样，你的大脑就会开始将那个数字视为重要的存在。你每天都要过滤成千上万条信息，但一旦某件事被编码为具有重要性，它就会直接从背景中凸显出来，对吧？这就像在人群中认出你熟悉且挚爱的人的脸一样。你会注意到它。你会注意到它。你会锁定它。这是对你很重要的东西。每次注意到它，它都与你相关。这种注意到它的事实，会让你觉得它
that obviously means something. And so that is the circular process of how an angel number becomes important to us and then continues to be something that we see. It's so insanely comforting. This is what I'm saying. It's so comforting. It is a good feeling. It is beautiful. The idea that things are connected, that life has pattern and meaning is a great way to live. And that brings me to another idea that's connected to angel numbers, which is pro noia.
显然有着某种特殊的含义。因此，这就是天使数字如何变得对我们重要、并进而继续成为我们频繁看到的数字的循环过程。这真的是无比宽慰人心。这就是我想说的。它太治愈了。这是一种美好的感觉。这是非常美妙的。万物相连、生活充满规律和意义，这种理念是一种很棒的生活方式。这也让我联想到了另一个与天使数字相关的概念，那就是顺性症。
Pronoia is described as the opposite of paranoia. Paranoia is the fear or belief that people, systems, or forces are kind of conspiring against you. Pro-noia, by contrast, is the sense that the world is conspiring in your favor. Now, this term was introduced into psychological literature by this guy called Fred Goldner. He was a sociologist at Queens College in New York, and he talked about it in this article he published in 1982. He described pronoia as a positive counterpart to paranoia, a belief that others think well of you, a belief that events are favorable. towards you rather than unfavorable, a belief that the social world is organized more benevolently
Pronioa（顺势疗法/顺势思维）被描述为偏执狂的反面。偏执狂是指人们对人群、系统或某种力量正在合谋对抗你的一种恐惧或信念。相比之下，顺势思维则是一种世界正在合谋对你有利的感觉。这个词是由一个叫弗雷德·戈尔德纳（Fred Goldner）的人引入心理学文献的。他是纽约皇后学院的一位社会学家，他在1982年发表的一篇文章中探讨了这个概念。他将顺势思维描述为偏执狂的积极对立面，即相信别人对你有好感，相信事件对你有利而不是不利，相信社会世界对你的组织更多是出于善意
around you than negatively around you. This is psychologically remarkable. It is psychologically powerful and it's basically a more scientific version of what you focus on expands. If you focus on the good, that expands. If you focus on the bad, if you let paranoia take over, the bad becomes your life. Pronoia means that there is benevolence in the timings of things. that things might be aligning, even if you do not fully understand how they are right now. It means that you are protected. Angel numbers create this gentle form of pro noia and this greatest sense of responsiveness to life because we feel more confident that things are going to go our way.
而不是恶意的。这在心理上是非常了不起的。它在心理上非常强大，基本上可以说是“你关注什么，什么就会扩大”这一规律的科学版。如果你关注美好，美好就会扩大。如果你关注糟糕的事情，如果你让偏执狂占据上风，糟糕的事情就会成为你的生活。顺势思维意味着事情的发生时机中蕴含着善意，意味着事情可能会朝着对你有利的方向发展，即使你目前还无法完全理解它们是如何做到的。这意味着你受到了保护。天使数字创造了这种温和的顺势思维形式，并对生活产生了最强烈的反应，因为我们更加确信事情会朝着对我们有利的方向发展。
And this is the part of angel numbers that can't be dismissed. Whether you think they're pseudoscience or not, they genuinely help people. They genuinely shape behavior in ways that do heal and do change lives and do spare growth. Uncertainty is emotionally and cognitively demanding and it makes us hesitate. It makes us stay still. It makes us remain motionless. When we do not know what is going to happen, our minds are going to try and fill that gap. Often it will fill that gap with anxiety and the worst case scenario.
这也是天使数字不能被忽视的一部分。不管你认为它们是伪科学与否，它们确实在帮助人们。它们确实在以真正治愈、改变生活并促进成长的方式塑造着行为。不确定性在情感和认知上都是具有挑战性的，它会让我们犹豫不决。它让我们停滞不前。它让我们保持静止。当我们不知道会发生什么时，我们的大脑就会试图填补这个空白。通常，它会用焦虑和最坏的情况来填补这个空白。
Angel numbers fill that gap with hope. and fill that gap with promise. Instead of thinking like, what if everything goes wrong? Here is this thing that says, but what if I'm being guided? What if I need to trust and wait and see how this unwinds? What if I need to just give it a go? That is psychologically powerful. That is psychologically powerful because deep down, you know the reality that you want. The angel number is just the boost. It's just the catalyst. It doesn't change the external outcome. Seeing a certain number doesn't guarantee that you're going to get the job. It doesn't guarantee that your relationship is going to work out, but it does guarantee that your
天使数字用希望填补了这个空白，用承诺填补了这个空白。与其去想“万一一切都搞砸了怎么办？”，这里有这样一种说法：“但万一我正在被引导呢？万一我需要去信任、等待并看看事情如何发展呢？万一我只需要去尝试一下呢？”这在心理上是非常强大的。这在心理上非常强大，因为在内心深处，你知道你想要的是什么现实。天使数字只是一种推动力。它只是一个催化剂。它并没有改变外部的结果。看到某个数字并不能保证你能得到这份工作。它不能保证你的关系会有好结果，但它确实能保证你的
internal state is probably going to be a lot more regulated. It does kind of ensure that you're going to feel more self-assured and calm. And what is definitely a fact is that that emotional state does have an impact on an outcome and does have an impact on how you choose to behave. There was a really interesting 2010 paper published in psychological science by the researchers Liz Zandamish and Barbara Stobarok. Their work basically examines superstition. It examines confidence and performance. And what their experiments found, and this is so critical, is that activating good luck
内外部状态可能会得到更好的调节。它确实在某种程度上确保了你会感到更加自信和冷静。毫无疑问，这种情绪状态确实会对结果产生影响，并对你选择如何行为产生影响。2010年，《心理科学》（Psychological Science）杂志上发表了一篇非常有趣的论文，作者是研究人员莉兹·赞达米什（Liz Zandamish）和芭芭拉·斯托巴罗克（Barbara Stobarok）。他们的研究主要探讨了迷信。它探讨了自信与表现之间的关系。他们的实验发现，而且这一点至关重要，激活好运
superstitions, like using a lucky object or hearing a phrase associated with luck, could improve performance not by changing an outcome, but by changing confidence and changing participants' levels of persistence because they felt like there was somebody on their side. Another study found something similar. When you show people certain symbols or make certain coincidences occur before they walk into an experimental condition and you say, hey, did you see that thing? Did you know that's lucky? It could literally be the most arbitrary thing. It literally could be nothing and they perform better because they feel safer and they feel like something is on their side.
迷信，比如使用幸运物或听到与好运相关的短语，可以通过改变自信心和参与者的坚持水平来提高表现，而不是通过改变结果，因为他们觉得有人站在他们这一边。另一项研究也发现了类似的结果。当你向人们展示某些符号，或者在他们走入实验条件之前让他们经历某些巧合，然后你对他们说：“嘿，你看到那个东西了吗？你知道那是幸运的吗？”这可能真的是最随意的事件。它可能完全没有任何意义，但他们的表现会更好，因为他们感到更安全，觉得有什么东西站在他们这一边。
There is obviously a term for this in psychology. There's a term for everything in psychology. It's a self-fulfilling prophecy. You've probably heard this before. A self-fulfilling prophecy. Of course that was going to happen. I talked about it, I think, in our superstition episode, I'm going to say, for a little refresher, a self-fulfilling prophecy occurs when a belief influences behavior in a way that makes the belief more likely to come true. Is that a bad thing? No, if the belief is positive. If you believe something is a sign of your
在心理学中，这显然有一个专有名词。心理学中对什么都有一个专有名词。这就是自证预言。你可能以前听过这个词。自证预言。这本来就是意料之中的事。我想我在我们的迷信那一期节目中谈到过它，不过为了复习一下，自证预言是指某种信念以一种使该信念更有可能成为现实的方式影响了行为。这是一件坏事吗？不，如果这种信念是积极的话。如果你相信某事是你
success, you are more likely to act in ways that bring about success. You are more likely to be audacious, you're more likely to be risky, you're more likely to put yourself out there. That is a good thing. That is what changes the outcome. With angel numbers, the self-fulfilling prophecy is so apparent and so powerful, probably more powerful than many other things. If you keep seeing one-one-one and you interpret it as a sign of a new beginning, guess what you're going to do? You're going to finally start that project. You're going to finally apply for that course. You're going to send that email. You're going to move cities. The number did not magically create the new beginning. It just helped you act in alignment with the one you already knew you wanted.
成功的标志，你就更有可能采取能够带来成功的行动。你更有可能表现得大胆，更有可能去冒险，更有可能展现自己。这是一件好事。这才是改变结果的因素。对于天使数字来说，自证预言是如此明显且强大，可能比许多其他事情都要强大。如果你一直看到111，并将其解读为一个新开始的标志，你猜你会怎么做？你最终会开始那个项目。你最终会申请那门课程。你会发送那封电子邮件。你会搬去不同的城市。这个数字并没有神奇地创造出新的开始。它只是帮助你采取与你早已知道自己想要的相一致的行动。
You are the magic. That's what I'm trying to say. You are the magic pushing your destiny forward. The angel number is just the security blanket. They're just letting you lean into what you already know you are capable of, whether that is growth, whether that is healing, whether that is peace, love, success, you name it. But you are the magic. They cannot change your reality. They cannot change your reality for you. You change your reality through their psychological impact. I really want to like emphasize this point. Often we already know things before we are willing to admit them. You already know you're unhappy. You already know you are outgrowing something. You know that that relationship isn't right. You know that you want something more from life. But that sensation is really frightening.
你就是魔法。这就是我想表达的意思。你才是推动你命运前行的魔法。天使数字只是安全毯。它们只是让你倾向于你已经知道自己有能力做到的事情，无论是成长、治愈、平静、爱、成功，应有尽有。但你才是魔法。它们无法改变你的现实。它们无法为你改变现实。你是通过它们的心理影响来改变现实的。我真的很想强调这一点。通常在我们愿意承认之前，我们心里就已经知道了。你已经知道自己不快乐了。你已经知道你在超越某种现状。你知道那段关系是不对的。你知道你想要生活中有更多的东西。但这种感觉真的很可怕。
It's really scary and it's uncertain when you know that you're going to have to change something and that things aren't going to be the same, or that there is an outcome that you can't 100% predict. So we need a psychological boost. We need a psychological push. So we look for a sign. We look for a sign. And if it's there, amazing because we act. Same can be said for tarot cards, for reading horoscopes. We just want a reason. But the fact that we're looking for a guide doesn't mean that the motivation to change isn't already there. And doesn't mean that we wouldn't have done it anyways. When somebody is looking for a sign, they're going to find a sign. When you know you need to do something, you're going to find something that's going to confirm that.
当你明知道自己必须改变某些事情，事情将不再一如既往，或者结果无法百分之百预测时，这真的很吓人，也充满了不确定性。所以我们需要心理上的推动。我们需要心理上的鼓舞。因此我们在寻找一个标志。我们在寻找一个标志。如果它出现了，那就太棒了，因为我们会付诸行动。塔罗牌和看星座运势也是同样的道理。我们只是想要一个理由。但我们在寻找指引并不意味着改变的动力原本就不存在。这也不意味着如果没有它我们本来就不会这么做。当一个人在寻找一个标志时，他就会找到一个标志。当你明知自己需要做某件事时，你就会找到能够证实这一点的东西。
Let's talk about why angel numbers get a bad rap. Should we, including a little bit more about the more dangerous, the more dangerous mixings with psychology. Stay with us. to see Cameron Whitcomb at the legendary Rhyman Auditorium Plus a thousand dollar spending cash Just listen to Pure Country for 10 minutes a day on the free IHard radio app And you're in to win Cameron Wickham
我们来聊聊为什么天使数字的名声不太好。难道不应该吗？其中还包括一点关于它与心理学之间更危险的结合。请收听，以赢得在传奇莱曼礼堂（Rhyman Auditorium）观看卡梅伦·惠特科姆（Cameron Whitcomb）演出的机会，外加一千美元的零花钱。只需在免费的IHeart电台应用上每天收听Pure Country 10分钟，你就有机会赢得卡梅伦·威肯（Cameron Wickham）
Stream the new single Kingdom of Fear Available now Hey Portlandia fans Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here You know us or rather you know them Tony and Candace Nina and Lance Spike and yes the chicken
串流收听新单曲《恐惧王国》（Kingdom of Fear），现已上线。嘿，Portlandia（波特兰迪亚）的粉丝们，凯瑞·布朗斯坦（Carrie Brownstein）和弗雷德·阿米森（Fred Armisen）在这里。你们认识我们，或者更准确地说，你们认识他们——托尼（Tony）和坎迪斯（Candace）、尼娜（Nina）和兰斯（Lance）、斯派克（Spike），还有那只鸡。
We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea?
多年来，我们扮演过许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以自我的身份出现，来向大家介绍我们的全新播客《波特兰迪亚重温》（Podlandia AEO rewatch）。每周，我们将从头开始重温一集《波特兰迪亚》，剖析短剧，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重访你们熟悉并喜爱的波特兰拍摄地点，并袒露我们的创作过程。这一切到底是怎么拍出来的？为什么我们当时会觉得那是个好主意？
We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life, guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song for it. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们已经准备好聊聊这些了。将把所有这些带入现实的人们也将加入我们，包括客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，其中包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔（Jonathan Chrysall）、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle McLaughlin）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌、一段旋律。我以为他会写。我以为你们所有人都会为此写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《波特兰迪亚：Ayo重温》（Podlandia. Ayo rewatch）。
Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show is famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on. We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller. The definition of what is a movie has kind of changed anywhere too, right? What do you think it is now?
嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）的主持人。每一集我们都在努力帮助我们的嘉宾改善他们的职业生涯，主要侧重于他们如何能帮助我们改善我们的职业生涯。这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，所以你可以轻松地跳进我们的650集节目中的任何一集，并听懂我们在聊什么。我们推荐一些我们最近邀请本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller）的节目。电影的定义其实在任何地方都有所改变，对吧？你觉得它现在是什么？
It's images and words being spoken, captured by some sort of technology. Danny McBride. Oh, that's fantastic. And you make it on, you make your own. That's great. I call him Terro Reed. It's a good name. They're all named after cast members of American Pie.
它是被某种技术捕捉到的正在被说出的图像和词语。丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride）。哦，那太棒了。而且你是自己制作的，你自己制作的。那太棒了。我叫他特罗·里德（Terro Reed）。这是个好名字。他们都是以《美国派》（American Pie）的演员命名的。
Yeah. I call, I don't, I never looked up if she was in this, but I call him Leachie Sobieski. Yeah. I don't think she was an American Pie, but I still like that. Haven't looked it up. She was prominent around the same time. Yeah. Then Mary Steenbergin.
对。我叫——我从来没查过她是不是演了这个，但我叫她利奇·索别斯基（Leachie Sobieski）。对。我不认为她演过《美国派》，但我还是喜欢这个名字。没去查过。她当时挺活跃的。对。然后是玛丽·斯汀伯根（Mary Steenbergin）。
Why are you guys talking to me? I'm worried. I'm worried. Why are you talking so down to me? me that you think I don't understand your little play game. I just really, I get it. I'm trying to set you up for success here. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
你们为什么要跟我说话？我很担心。我很担心。你们为什么用这种居高临下的态度跟我说话？你们觉得我听不懂你们的小把戏吗？我真的，我懂。我只是想为你们的成功做好铺垫。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。
This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check you. Okay? Hey, if you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm gonna play you. Join Yamanika Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast.
我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。亚曼妮卡（Yamanika）来到这里，是为了告诉任何应该负责的人：你才是问题所在。如果你来这里玩游戏，我会查你的。好吗？嘿，如果你在新闻里做了什么听起来不太好的事，我要曝光你。和亚曼妮卡·桑德斯（Yamanika Saunders）一起，在她的新播客中剖析本周最具问题的故事。
You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. So join Yomeneke, each episode. as she answers one question. Who's the problem?
亚曼妮卡带你直面问题（You're the problem with Yamanika）。你知道我刚刚发现西德尼·斯威尼（Sidney Sweeney）是谁吗？每周三更新新节目，作为我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”（the Dear Chelsea Network）的一部分。如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。所以请每一集都加入亚曼妮卡，
I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman.
因为她回答了一个问题。谁才是问题所在？我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《亚曼妮卡带你直面问题》（you're the problem with Yamanika）。我是尼克·托托罗（Nick Totoro）。你可能从《纽约重案组》（NYPD Blue）、《最长的一码》（The Longest Yard）或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》（Black Klansman）中认识我。
But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins.
但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《用尼克·托托罗传递幸福》（delivering happiness with Nick Totoro）中，我把来自王子街披萨（Prince Street Pizza）的披萨送到新嘉宾手中。你现在开始送披萨了吗？然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我跟从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）开始的每个人都分享过一块披萨。
What are you doing, my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness.
你在干什么，我的腰带？到亚历克斯·罗德里格斯（Alex Rodriguez）。让你们知道，我们正在和这里的史上最佳之一对话。再到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我想我从来没遇到过哪个人的精神状态像我一样如此彻底地失控。现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·托图罗（John Tuturo）。这个节目叫《幸福》。传递幸福。
Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happen is with Nick Duturo. And listen now. So you know what I hate? I hate when people yuck other people's yum,
马里亚诺·里维拉（Mariano Rivera）。哦，天哪。还有很多很多其他人。打开你免费的High Heart Radio应用。搜索《用尼克·杜图罗传递幸福》（Delivering Happen is with Nick Duturo）。现在就听。所以你知道我讨厌什么吗？我讨厌别人扫别人的兴，
when it literally does no harm to them. Not even harm. Like, it doesn't even influence them in the slightest. It really annoys me. It really annoys me. And I think people who believe in angel numbers often get a lot of yuck from other people. And I just don't think that's fair.
而这实际上对他们没有任何伤害。甚至都谈不上伤害。就像，它甚至对他们没有丝毫影响一样。这真的很烦人。这真的让我很烦人。而且我认为相信天使数字的人经常会受到别人的奚落。而我觉得这很不公平。
And let's talk about it. I think people often make fun of angel numbers and people who believe in angel numbers because there's this idea that they're irrational and they're sentimental and it's really associated with this like delulu, like online spiritual culture of like luck and fate and destiny and like how unscientific is that. I think sometimes this criticism comes from a genuine concern that maybe angel numbers are encouraging magical thinking or poor decision making or, again, a confirmation bias that allows people to do things that maybe aren't wise. Like, if Angel Numbers can be a guide for positive things, they can also be a guide for things that maybe aren't what's best for you. Like getting back with people, you probably shouldn't, quitting jobs without a plan, that sort of thing. I think the concern can be fair,
我们来聊聊这个。我认为人们经常取笑天使数字和相信天使数字的人，因为有一种观点认为他们不理性、多愁善感，这真的与那种“delulu”（妄想）、网上的好运、命运和宿命的灵性文化联系在一起，这简直太不科学了。我认为有时这种批评源于一种真诚的担忧，即天使数字可能在助长魔幻思维、糟糕的决策，或者再次助长了一种确证偏误，使人们做出可能并不明智的事情。就像，如果天使数字可以成为积极事物的指南，它们也可能成为对你来说或许并非最好的事物的指南。比如和不该复合的人复合，没有计划就辞职，诸如此类的事情。我认为这种担忧是合理的，
especially if somebody's making major life choices based on only the presence of numbers without a plan. But a lot of the time, that's not why people are worried about it. A lot of the time, I think, people just want to criticize it. People just want to make you feel inferior. I think the mockery around angel numbers, specifically from a certain group of people, comes from a bit of a superiority complex. It becomes this way of like performing intelligence and performing detachment. There's often this tone when people criticize angel numbers of like, I'm more intelligent than you. I would never believe in that. I understand the science. You're dumb. I'm not. Well, I don't know, I understand the science. You understand the science. You just listen to 30 minutes of it.
特别是如果有人仅仅根据数字的出现而没有计划就做出重大的生活选择的话。但很多时候，人们担心并不是因为这个。很多时候，我认为人们只是想批评它。人们只是想让你感到自己低人一等。我认为围绕天使数字的嘲笑，特别是来自某特定人群的嘲笑，源于某种优越感。这变成了一种表现聪明和表现超然的方式。当人们批评天使数字时，往往带着这样的语气：“我比你聪明。我绝不会相信那种东西。我懂科学。你很蠢，而我不蠢。”嗯，我不知道，我懂科学。你懂科学。你只是听了30分钟的科学内容。
And I think that that science and that research makes angel numbers even more compelling in terms of the way that they psychologically guide people and the way that they emotionally provide courage that is needed for a human to act. Actually, in terms of the way that they enable agency and self-belief, I don't think that's something to be scoffed at. I actually think that is a remarkably powerful thing to have at your disposal. There's also a very gendered element here. Many forms of spiritual meaning making like taro, like angel numbers, like birth charts, which are also typically associated with young women, often receive an additional unfair amount of criticism as being cringe or silly or embarrassing or stupid.
而且我认为这些科学和研究使得天使数字在心理上引导人们的方式，以及它们在提供人类行动所需的勇气方面的方式，变得更加引人入胜。事实上，就它们能够激发主动性和自信心而言，我不认为这是什么好嘲笑的事情。我实际上认为，这是一种非常强大的、可供你支配的资源。这里还有一个非常明显的性别化因素。许多灵性意义的创造形式，比如塔罗牌、天使数字、出生星盘，这些通常也与年轻女性联系在一起，往往会受到额外的不公平的批评，被认为是幼稚、愚蠢、尴尬或无脑的。
It is almost a trend to mock them, to think of them as like, silly women, things and emotional and not rational and ridiculous and, you know, the man's view of life is about hard work and rationality and you believing in this shows that you don't believe in that. That's kind of an idea. Humans engage in symbolic and irrational rituals all the time. Athletes wear lucky clothing. Students use lucky pens. Football fans believe they can jinx a game by not doing a certain routine beforehand or doing a certain routine beforehand. People knock on wood. People say everything happens for a reason.
嘲笑它们几乎成了一种潮流，把它们视为幼稚女性的玩意儿、情绪化、不理性且荒谬的，你知道的，男性的生活观是关于辛勤工作和理性的，而你相信这些表明你不相信那些。这大概就是这样一种观点。人类一直在进行着象征性和非理性的仪式。运动员穿幸运服装。学生用幸运笔。足球球迷相信，如果他们不事先做某种常规动作，或者事先做了某种常规动作，他们就会给比赛带来霉运。人们敲木头。人们说一切发生皆有原因。
All of these things involve emotion. They involve symbolism, uncertainty and perceived meaning. And those things are the exact same psychological route as angel numbers. It's just packaged differently. The branding is literally just different. It's like the difference between Diet Coke and Coke Zero. It's just the gender that they're marketed towards. So we're not really talking about.
所有这些事情都涉及情感。它们涉及象征意义、不确定性和感知到的意义。而这些东西与天使数字具有完全相同的心理根源。只是包装不同而已。它们的品牌宣传完全不同。就像健怡可乐（Diet Coke）和零度可乐（Coke Zero）的区别一样。区别只在于它们所针对的营销性别。所以我们其实并不是在讨论
about a difference in rationality at all. The difference is actually more so in which rituals are socially legitimized, socially supported, and which aren't. I also think this mockery can come from, and maybe this is a stretch, but I think it is a discomfort with hope. Feeling hopeful can be really vulnerable. To believe that something might be working out for you is to risk disappointment. And cynicism protects you against that disappointment. If you never believe in signs, you never have to feel foolish for hoping, you can give distance. You can remain detached from longing and from wanting. And I think that's a really critical part that people don't talk about.
理性上的差异。这种差异实际上更多在于哪些仪式在社会上被合法化、被社会支持，而哪些没有。我也认为这种嘲笑可能源于——也许这有点勉强——但我认为这是对希望的一种不安。感到充满希望可能会让人感到非常脆弱。相信某事可能会对你有利，就是冒着失望的风险。而愤世嫉俗可以保护你免受这种失望。如果你从不相信任何征兆，你就永远不必为抱有希望而感到愚蠢，你可以保持距离。你可以与渴望和欲望保持超然。我认为这是一个人们不常谈论的至关重要的部分。
It's easy to not believe in angel numbers because believing in them would mean that like the possibility of something good is possible and you could have some hope around that. And then what if you're disappointed? There's some fear in that as well. So is it actually all that bad to believe in angel numbers? In most cases, no, it's not. In fact, it's maybe even a good thing. I would make the argument that it is.
不相信天使数字很容易，因为相信它们就意味着某种美好事情发生的可能性是存在的，而你可以围绕这一点抱有一些希望。然后万一你失望了呢？其中也存在一些恐惧。那么，相信天使数字真的有那么糟糕吗？在大多数情况下，没有，一点也不。事实上，这甚至可能是一件好事。我会为此进行辩护。
With anything, though, there are a few things to look out for, and I would be remiss if I didn't mention them, so I'm going to hear. I think the main things to be cautious of with anything in this kind of new age spiritual realm is exploitation. Any belief system that offers people comfort during periods of uncertainty and transition and confusion can also become something that is sold back to them and used to manipulate them. And that's just an annoying part of human existence. This is especially the case, in my opinion, in online spiritual spaces where we're sold more and more and more reassurance and more and more comfort packaged as personalized readings or intuitive messages from the universe.
不过，无论做什么，都有一些需要注意的事项，如果我不提出来，那就是我的失职了，所以我要在这里讲讲。我认为在这个新时代灵性领域中，对于任何事情都需要谨慎的主要事情是剥削。任何在不确定、转型和混乱时期为人们提供安慰的信仰体系，也可能变成被回售给他们并用来操纵他们的工具。这是人类生存中一件令人讨厌的事情。在我看来，在网络灵性空间中尤其如此，在那里我们被兜售越来越多的保证和越来越多的安慰，这些被包装成个性化的解读或来自宇宙的直觉信息，
when it may just be a way for somebody to make money off of you, and you have to kind of be aware of people's human urges to exploit. A lot of people earn money through spiritual work, and it's fair work, and it's important work. The issue is when certain people pry on people's vulnerabilities, pry on their anxiety in order to sell them a product, and their own belief in the product is not there, and their own good intentions are not there.
而这实际上可能只是某人从你身上赚钱的一种方式，你必须意识到人类剥削他人的冲动。很多人通过灵性工作赚钱，这是正当的工作，也是重要的工作。问题在于，某些人利用人们的脆弱性、利用他们的焦虑来向他们兜售产品，而他们自己对产品的信仰并不存在，他们自己也没有好的意图。
Someone may start with a harm, interest in angel numbers and slowly get pulled into this loop of needing more reassurance, one more reading, one more spiritual download, one more video telling them what this number means for this specific situation. And often the language used is really persuasive and really general, because it wants to speak to anybody who is in a place of emotional uncertainty. That's often all of us, you know. It wants to relate to everybody so that they can make more money. and so that they can kind of manipulate a system. And it is important to be aware of that and to be aware of the psychological power of angel numbers
某人可能最初出于对天使数字的无害兴趣，然后慢慢被拉入这样一个循环中：需要更多的保证，再来一次解读，再来一次灵性下载，再来看一个告诉他们这个数字对这个特定情况意味着什么的视频。而且通常使用的语言非常有说服力且非常笼统，因为它想迎合任何处于情感不确定状态的人。通常我们所有人都在其中，你知道的。它想要和所有人产生共鸣，这样他们就能赚更多的钱，并以此来操纵一个系统。意识到这一点非常重要，同时也要意识到天使数字的心理力量，
and what they can do in the comfort they can offer people. And just because we know that, it also means that people who have bad intentions know that as well. And we have to be aware as well of a dependency on external confirmation that some of these processes can create. Instead of learning to sit with ambiguity, to tolerate uncertainty, to just like trust your judgment, but sometimes we can get desperate in our search for angel numbers or a sign, and when it doesn't come, it can be awful. It can be awful.
以及它们能做什么、能为人们提供什么安慰。正因为我们知道这一点，这也意味着那些心怀不轨的人同样知道这一点。我们还必须意识到，其中一些过程可能会产生对外部确证的依赖。我们没有学会如何安于模糊、如何容忍不确定性、如何只是去信任自己的判断，有时我们在寻找天使数字或征兆时会变得绝望，而当它没有出现时，情况可能会变得很糟糕。情况可能会很糟糕。
And I want to say, again, a lot of people engage with spiritual practices in a very sincere, honest, helpful way and an ethical way and with an intention of really guiding people, but it's just worth being cautious, and it's just worth knowing your source a little bit more. and also being okay with a little bit of uncertainty. Like, it's okay. It's okay to not know. Also, look at the example of Doreen Virtue, who we spoke about earlier.
我想再次说明，很多人以非常真诚、诚实、有益和道德的方式参与灵性实践，并且抱有真正引导人们的意图，但了解这一点并保持谨慎是值得的，多了解一下你的信息来源也是值得的。同时也要坦然接受一点不确定性。这没关系。不知道也没关系。另外，看看我们之前谈到的朵琳·维秋（Doreen Virtue）的例子。
Here is a woman who made millions and millions and millions of people and then basically reneged and said, oh, I don't believe in that. And this article I was speaking about talks about these individuals who were just left, like, heartbroken and they'd made major life decisions on this woman's teachings. They felt very scammed, they felt very misled, they felt even more confused because she's just a human. Humans are fallible. It's difficult to put our hopes and fears at their feet. One more thing that I think we should be aware of is the fixation and anxiety that can come with our belief in angel numbers.
这是一个女人，她让数百万、数百万、数百万的人掏了钱，然后基本上反悔并说：“哦，我不相信那个。”我谈到的这篇文章讨论了这些个人，他们被抛弃了，心碎了，他们根据这个女人的教导做出了重大的生活决定。他们感到自己被严重欺骗了，被严重误导了，感到更加困惑，因为她只是个人类。人类是会犯错的。把我们的希望和恐惧寄托在他们身上是很难的。我认为我们还应该注意的另一件事是，对天使数字的信仰可能带来的执念和焦虑。
Not for everybody, but as much as there are positive encouraging messages that come from angel numbers and seeing 222 or 1234 or 444 everywhere, the opposite can also be true. If we start to fixate on good numbers, we can also start to fixate on bad numbers, maybe interpreting certain numbers as omens or warnings or signs that something is going wrong. We can also, if we don't see our angel number every day or regularly, we can start to feel exceedingly unsure of a decision. Like, I'm not getting confirmation of this. Is this a right decision? Maybe it is, even if there's not a number to support that.
并非对每个人都如此，但正如天使数字以及到处看到222、1234或444会带来积极鼓舞的信息一样，反之亦然。如果我们开始执着于好数字，我们也会开始执着于坏数字，可能会把某些数字解读为凶兆、警告或某些事情出错的征兆。如果我们没有每天或定期看到我们的天使数字，我们也可能会对某个决定感到极其不确定。就像，我没有得到这件事的确认。这是一个正确的决定吗？也许是的，即使没有数字来支持这一点。
We can get into this trap of black and white thinking, where we're trying to predict the future based on these neutral numbers that we notice. At that point, the practice can shift from being a source of courage and meaning making and motivation and magic to being a big component of disorders like anxiety and OCD. If you're wading around to see if there is a numerical sign to make a decision about your life,
我们可能会陷入黑白思维的陷阱，试图根据我们注意到的这些中立数字来预测未来。在那个时候，这种实践可能会从勇气、意义建构、动机和魔法的源泉，转变为焦虑和强迫症（OCD）等障碍的一个重要组成部分。如果你在四处观望，看是否有数字符号来决定你的生活，
or if you are being put off doing something you know you need to do because of a so-called bad number or because you haven't seen a good number, then I think that is the point where, not everybody gets here, but it is the point where you might need to take a step back and just be like, is this belief making my life bigger or smaller? Belief, it's in the word, needs to make your life bigger. I think I would take it back to that cool message. At the end of the day, you are the magic and you are the decision maker.
或者如果你因为所谓的坏数字或者因为没有看到好数字而推迟做你明知自己需要做的事情，那么我认为这就是那个时刻——虽然不是每个人都会走到这一步——但这是你可能需要退后一步，然后问自己：“这种信念是在让我的生活变得更大还是更小？”信仰，正如这个词本身所暗示的，需要让你的生活变得更大。我想我会把它拉回到那个很酷的信息上。归根结底，你才是魔法，你才是决策者。
You are the one who has the say, you are conscious, You make things happen. You do the healing. You push your own evolution forward. If you need a sign, if you need encouragement, that is not a bad thing. Every human needs motivation in some form. Angel numbers don't do the work for you though. And they aren't the final be or say or end all of this situation. Again, I want to say I love the concept of angel numbers. They have provided so much comfort for me during really difficult times. I went through a really terrible breakup. Angel numbers played a great role. When I moved cities and I felt really, really lonely, they were a guiding light for me.
你是那个拥有最终决定权的人，你是有意识的。你能让事情发生。你在进行自我治愈。你在推动你自己的演化前进。如果你需要一个标志，如果你需要鼓励，那并不是一件坏事。每个人都需要某种形式的动力。不过，天使数字并不能替你完成工作。它们也不是这种情况下的最终决定因素或终点。再次说明，我想说我很喜欢天使数字的概念。在非常艰难的时期，它们为我提供了极大的安慰。我经历了一场非常糟糕的分手。天使数字在其中发挥了巨大的作用。当我搬到不同的城市并感到非常非常孤独时，它们对我来说是一盏指路明灯。
When I wanted to quit my job, I'm not going to lie and say I didn't see a 2-2-2-2. I think that was a good choice. They made the ordinary feel less hard and they made my life feel more meaningful and significant. And I think the science behind why they made me feel that way makes them even more important to me because it confirms that what I'm searching for, if I'm searching for something I obviously already secretly unconsciously want it. And so if I am looking for a sign, the fact I am looking for a sign is the sign.
当我想要辞职时，我不会撒谎说我没有看到2222。我认为那是一个正确的选择。它们让平常的事情感觉没那么艰难，并让我的生活感觉更有意义和重要性。我认为它们让我产生这种感觉背后的科学原理让它们对我而言更加重要，因为它证实了我所寻找的东西——如果我在寻找某种东西，我显然在内心深处无意识地渴望它。所以如果我在寻找一个标志，我正在寻找标志这一事实本身就是那个标志。
Does that make sense? Yeah, again, I think it does. If you are looking for a sign, that is your sign. So there you go. That is the psychology of angel numbers, a little bit of the history as well. That is why they are so compelling to us psychologically. I don't think that science undermines them.
这说得通吗？是的，再说一次，我认为确实如此。如果你在寻找一个标志，那这就是你的标志。所以，就是这样。这就是天使数字的心理学，还有一点历史。这就是为什么它们在心理上对我们如此具有吸引力。我不认为科学会贬低它们。
I think it actually contributes to them. So I hope that you've learned something. I hope it's made you feel more informed about this practice. If you've made it this far and you're listening on Spotify, what's your favorite angel number? Leave a comment down below. If you also see 1234 everywhere, let me know. What does it mean for you?
我认为科学实际上对它们有所贡献。所以我希望你们学到了一些东西。我希望这能让你们对这种实践有更多的了解。如果你已经听到了这里，并且正在Spotify上收听，你最喜欢的天使数字是什么？在下方留言。如果你也到处都能看到1234，请让我知道。这对你意味着什么？
I want to see, I know I'm not the only one. So who else is out there? I want to hear from you. Thank you as always to our researcher Libby Colbert for her. incredible help with this episode and her amazing research. We also have some fun additional pieces of research and further reading on the topic of angel numbers in the description. You can also find out more on Substack. You can join our Study of the Week group. You can watch an episode on Netflix. Everywhere you can find us, you can find us in the description. Just go down there and there's
我想看看，我知道我不是唯一一个。还有谁在那里？我想听到你们的声音。一如既往地感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）为本期节目提供的难以置信的帮助和她惊人的研究。我们在描述中还提供了一些有趣的其他研究资料和关于天使数字主题的延伸阅读。你还可以在Substack上了解更多信息。你可以加入我们的“每周研究”小组。你可以在Netflix上观看一集节目。我们能找到你的所有地方，你都可以在描述中找到。只要往下看，那里
actually so much interesting stuff that you can go down a whole rabbit hole with this even further if you want to. But again, yes, thank you for listening. I love this episode. I love doing like these scientific episodes into like real common concepts, especially ones that are a little bit mystical. So I hope you enjoyed it as well. And until next time, be safe, be kind. Be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit
其实有非常多有趣的东西，如果你愿意的话，你可以顺着这个线索深入探索下去。但再次感谢大家的收听。我很喜欢这一集。我喜欢把这些科学的研究方法应用到一些非常常见的概念中，尤其是那些带有一点神秘色彩的概念。所以我希望你们也喜欢。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良。对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，波特兰迪亚的粉丝们。凯瑞·布朗斯坦和弗雷德·阿米森在这里。90年代的梦想在播客形式中依然活着。我们正在推出《波特兰迪亚：A.O.重温》（Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch），这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温
every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chryssel, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song.
《波特兰迪亚》的每一集，剖析短剧，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。将把所有这些带入现实的人们也将加入我们。客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，其中包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、传奇音乐家艾米·曼等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴了。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们所有人都会写首歌。
I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. AEO rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Every episode we're trying to help our guests improve their careers by mainly focusing on how they can help us improve our careers. The show's famously super accessible so you can easily jump into any of our 650 episodes and understand what's going on.
我记得你是这么想的。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《波特兰迪亚：AEO重温》（Podlandia. AEO rewatch）。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特。还有肖恩·克莱门茨。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。每一集我们都在努力帮助我们的嘉宾改善他们的职业生涯，主要侧重于他们如何能帮助我们改善我们的职业生涯。这个节目以超级平易近人而闻名，所以你可以轻松地跳进我们的650集节目中的任何一集，并听懂我们在聊什么。
We recommend some of our recent episodes with Ben Stiller, Danny McBride, Riz Ahmed, and Mary Steenberg. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the I. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Titoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, The Longest Yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Titoro, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt?
我们推荐一些我们最近邀请本·斯蒂勒、丹尼·麦克布莱德、里兹·艾哈迈德（Riz Ahmed）和玛丽·斯汀伯根的节目。请在I Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）。我是尼克·托托罗。你可能从《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。在我的新播客《用尼克·托托罗传递幸福》中，我把披萨送到新嘉宾手中。我跟从赛斯·罗林斯开始的每个人都分享过一块披萨。你在干什么，我的腰带？
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tituro. It's called happiness. Delivering happiness. And many, many more. Open your free high-heart radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutor.
到比尔·伯尔。我想我从来没遇到过哪个人的精神状态像我一样如此彻底地失控。现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·托图罗。这个节目叫幸福。传递幸福。还有很多很多其他人。打开你免费的高心电台（High Heart Radio）应用。搜索《用尼克·杜图罗传递幸福》（Delivering Happiness with Nick Tutor）。
And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out
现在就听。这是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。亚曼妮卡来到这里，是为了告诉任何应该负责的人：你才是问题所在。你知道我刚刚发现
who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nancy Glass, host of the Burden of Guilt Season 3 podcast.
西德尼·斯威尼是谁吗？如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《亚曼妮卡带你直面问题》（You're the Problem with Yamanika）。我是南希·格拉斯（Nancy Glass），《负罪感背负者》（The Burden of Guilt）第三季播客的主持人。
This is a story about a horrendous situation that destroyed two families. It's a scorched earth war that shows just how far someone will go to get what they want. Cindy said I had to choose between the truth and my family, and I had to choose the truth. Listen to Season 3 A Burden of Guilt on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是一个关于摧毁了两个家庭的可怕状况的故事。这是一场焦土政策般的战争，它展示了一个人为了得到自己想要的东西可以走多远。辛迪（Cindy）说我必须在真相和我的家庭之间做出选择，我必须选择真相。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听第三季《负罪感背负者》（A Burden of Guilt）。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。